the game seemingly confirms which
Kardashians he slept with sometimes it
gets late at night and you know it just
people i don't know the 36 year old
rapper was a guest on the Wendy Williams
Show on Tuesday where she pressed him on
the rumors that started swirling after
his single sauce was released last month
you do what you want to do did you do
Chloe yeah in the track the game wraps
then I pop3 Kardashians hold that
thought Chloe in the wrapper were
roommates back in the day making her an
obvious choice but the other two were up
for speculation did you get down with
Courtney no Kim I'll tell you this calle
is a really good friend of mine and they
got really really beautiful kids and I
don't want to disrespect their family
okay and game revealed to Wendy the
third Kardashian technically isn't a
Kardashian yet it gets a little tricky
and dropped the mic with his tricky
answer seemingly alluding to hooking up
with Rob Kardashian's fiance and baby
mama blac Chyna China Mary
you